[Music]  swear your oath marines die  i swear to speak no word that is not  true  to make no weapon with which one person  may kill another  and never to use the one power as a  weapon  do you know what i said i mean in the  old town  servants of all  [Music]  it is they who serve the world  i didn't choose this path but i will  follow it  where next the two rivers the old blood  runs deep in those mountains  let's hope it's prepared then for what's  coming  the dark one is waking  but there will be one who can stand  against him  and it's one of the five of you  you fully lost your mind  your life isn't going to be what you  thought  what are those  his army is coming  what can we do  our enemies are everywhere  they will leave no one standing  we've lost too many people already back  home  you won't  if we do not stop the dark one now  the whole world will burn  i can't allow it  the wheel weaves as the wheel wills  do you think we'll ever go back  home  no  [Music]  you